Sam Donald add mono last year he's not
concerned about getting kovat 19 this
year he said on Monday I trust the
authorities to do their due diligence
and make sure we're safe coming back as
long as we're allowed to be in the
facility and be practicing and be
playing games I'm not going to be
worried about it and look that doesn't
mean he's not concerned about getting it
we all should be concerned about getting
it because it's got this random quality
where it ravages some people and it
doesn't ravage others and yes health
factors an age or a key but there are
young healthy people who are suffering
from it to the point is once you get the
clearance to enter the facility at that
point you shouldn't worry about it if
they have the right measures to make
sure that you don't get in unless you
test negative and I've also said you
don't get out unless you test negative
as well so that the general public
doesn't have to worry about what you may
have caught at the facility you just go
about your job you go about your work
and Chris you've set a time and again
football players aren't gonna care about
this they are dealing with far more
immediate physical risks then what
happens if they end up with the corona
virus in their body they're dealing with
broken bones ligament sprains
concussions neck injuries potential
emergency splenectomy Xand I'm not
trying to be funny about that there's a
risk of something far more immediate
than whatever the corona virus could do
to you and so on the list of things
football players should worry about this
should be fairly far down the list well
this is where you know we haven't really
delved down this this you know wormhole
a whole lot yet as far as where our
players at and their thoughts on this
copán 19 process I mean you're right
Mike first off hey these are modern-day
gladiators I think a lot of them don't
care I think a lot of them think I'm
young I'm healthy
you know I'll listen to the Cova 19
measures and be protected because they
love them to have people around them
they want to protect but you know hey
yeah I mean I think between that and
then you have a short shelf life in the
NFL you know here you got guys sitting
here this these are legacy changing
moments you know I keep sitting here
thinking about like LeBron James he's on
his you know I'm trying to win his
fourth championship and chase Michael
Jordan do all those things
his legacy could be forever change
because of Coppa 19 and you know these
players I think it's the same thing you
know you think about the average years
you have in the NFL and how long you can
play you know I just I would like at
some point Mike don't you think we have
to get a gauge for where the players are
at like I heard some major league
baseball players talking about this last
night yeah we can talk about all these
scenarios and everything but at some
point do they need to take a vote from
the players to go hey how many of us are
comfortable with you know certain
guidelines or certain things if they're
not covered all the way you're not
getting tested every day and on the way
out on the way in that's why I have a
right okay Union the Union does it for
you and they've reached an agreement to
come back and play baseball with an
82-game season so that's a no brainer
and that's why the NFL Players
Association Chris is going to be so
critical to what the NFL altima does and
the one thing the NFL PA has it's the
ultimate hammer that rarely gets
mentioned anywhere but here and I'm
careful saying that because we know that
nobody's talking about it but literally
no one is talking about this if there's
no football season this year the way the
NFL CBA is written the players are
entitled to full pay which is one of the
reasons why the NFL is determined to
play this year but as they negotiate
with the Players Association the terms
with which the NFL would exist in 2020
the NFL PA has to agree to any major
changes to the work rules in the NFL PA
can just sit back and say sorry we don't
like that no we don't like this no we
have this concern know we have that
concern but that's how the voice of the
individual player is going to resonate
in this process through his Union the ml
BPA has already done it and they're
going to come back reportedly in July
and the NFL PA at some point is gonna
have a major seat at the table Chris to
figure out what NFL players should and
shouldn't be expected to deal with yeah
I mean I just you know I just feel like
we need to hear from the masses of
players at some point you know and again
and I know you're right the NFL PA is
gonna take care of all that and the
union reps and all that will be there
too
for the players but Mike I guess you
know the big thing to me Nido do we know
because I don't know this and I know
you're smarter than me in this area
especially like our if there's no season
I mean you you don't think the owners
are gonna be able to wiggle out from not
paying the players you know that's where
I status
they'll try I'll try they'll try but the
CBA is what it is and how many times do
we have people and they know who they
are people in the media that the moment
there's anything that goes against the
players they puff out their chest and
say well that's what you get for
negotiating a CBA
that has this term in that term in this
term in that term well great point those
people who are ready to crap
sorry UK on the NFLPA every time there's
a bad outcome under the CBA there's an
arbitration ruling they don't like when
it's time to say well hey NFL all you
had to do was put a force majeure clause
in your CBA with sufficient specificity
like the NBA has the NBA has its players
over a barrel Chris thanks to the force
majeure clause the only breaks in the
NFL has is if games are actually
cancelled this year there's an
obligation by the Union to engage in
good-faith negotiations about what the
salary cap will be next year there is
nothing in there in the mere fact that
they've they've contemplated cancelled
games and the impact on next year's
salary cap it tells you that hey they
could have put something in about the
current year in any given year of the
CBA so that y'all they'll try there's
too much money at stake for them that's
right frivolous argument and take it to
somebody and hope that you get a
favorable judge who will ignore the
plain language of the CBA that happens
all the time in many contacts with
contracts and legal principles you just
hope that you get a judge that wants to
rule for you and we'll find a way to do
it that is a reality of the legal system
but when I look at the CBA when I look
at the individual player contract I'm
not seeing anything in there that
protects the NFL against having to pay
the players in full if there's no season
in 2020 well that's that's yes so that's
really interesting to me I mean yes I
would think that the of course the
owners tried to wiggle out of that in
some capacity and there's no games
played and nothing
and this is where I wanted to go with
this mic because this is the question I
want to pose to you you know does the
the owners hurt their case even more if
there's let's just say week 1 and week 2
or played and then all sudden we hear
like four or five guys in the NFL right
they got coded 19 and now okay we got to
take a three or four week hiatus and not
play now that's where I would go if I'm
the owners I would think ooh
they'd have to be worried that hey the
season started guys that play games guys
are gonna go I want my guaranteed money
I don't care you guys cancelled this
season I didn't dime here whatever blah
blah blah I just was wondering if that
made them more liable that way but you
kind of answered my question where it
sounds like the W liable regardless okay
okay let me tell you this and I'll
because I can't because we have to take
a break soon when it first came up about
the NBA possibly not paying players
based upon the language of their CBA and
I looked up the CBA and I found the
provision the Force Majeure clause fancy
term for saying basically stuff happens
and sometimes off happens that isn't our
responsibility happening exactly and we
all have to pay you so I went straight
to the NFL's CBA to look for some and I
searched it 20 different ways with 20
different terms and there's nothing in
there and I bounced off a high-level
source with one of the teams this idea
that hey you know what if there's no
season you're gonna have to pay all your
guys and and this person told me that
that the the argument will be if there's
no games at all the players don't get
paid if there's only one game the
players do get paid in full now no basis
I have no reading that I see in the CBA
that would support that but again
nothing stops them from going out and
hiring high-priced lawyers and saying
this is the argument we want you to make
happens all the time especially when the
people writing the checks are incredibly
rich but you know you've touched on this
the way the schedule is constructed damn
the torpedoes for week right we are
going forward what if it Ottomans up
being only week one well maybe they got
to pay them in full but this is why
Chris I keep coming back to no matter
what form it takes no matter where they
go and there are reports already of
teams doing tree
Camp in other states look teams will
play games in other states if they have
to they're gonna get these two hundred
and fifty six games in even if they do
have to go to area 51 even if they do
have to take all the teams to Florida
even if they have to find an island
somewhere they are getting these games
in because number one they want the TV
money and number two they have to pay
their players one way or the other and I
think deep down they know it alright
let's take a break we'll be talking
about these issues plenty in the coming
weeks as we get to the point where we
know or at least think we know what the
NFL season is going to look like
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports